more people are expected to fly this
year for the Thanksgiving holiday is
that good or bad airlines say 28 and a
half million passengers will take
flights over the 12-day holiday period
that's up three percent from last year
DeMarco Morgan is at Newark Liberty
International Airport in New Jersey with
more DeMarco good morning good morning
today is one of the busiest travel days
of the year the TSA is expected to
screen more than 26 million people
during the 12-day Thanksgiving travel
period and according to triple-a
consumers are paying around 23 percent
less for flights this year that's a good
thing a round-trip flight is averaging
around one hundred fifty seven dollars
the cheapest since 2013 but travelers
won't be so lucky a French in a car 89
percent of Thanksgiving travelers will
be driving and the daily Car Rental
price is up 34 percent from last year
drivers will also have to pay the
highest Thanksgiving gas prices since
2014 a tank of gas is averaging two
dollars and 54 cents a gallon 37% from
last November and a TSA tip this is pro
folks who are planning to fly with food
you can take your turkey in your
carry-on but you have to check the gravy
so they can't go together at least when
it comes to traveling black okay I'll
remember that DeMarco but okay Thank You
DeMarco